j'aurais pu prendre le sac à main ça m'a
frappé vous avez vu la violence du coup
qu'il y met le mec dessus j'en sais mais
c'est pas avoir des couilles des trucs
comme ça et loteries film un film il pu
malgré les conneries qu'ils font et
voulait pas voir la haine vous si vous
allez devoir le mec je les tue tous les
trois mois je dis la même chose que vous
mais je vous le dis moi je dis un truc
je suis j'y vais en prison j'y vais en
prison pour tromper aussi de vos enfants
étaient aussi sous peu au cinéma
gilles je le comprends tout à fait mais
je suis choqué et je sais que c'est sans
doute minoritaire il vit un drame cette
affaire nous a bouleversés mais je ne
peux pas acquiescé quelqu'un qui dit
même sous le coup de l'émotion j'aurais
pu les tuer je pourrais les tuer parce
que si on accepte ça et encore une fois
il est légitime de le dire lui mais si
on accepte ça ça revient à dire que on
laisse quelqu'un dire que l'on peut se
venger que les pas y avoir une sorte de
légitime défense nouvellement créé donc
je suis choqué même si je le comprends
mais je suis obligé de répondre oui j'y
lis à des risques il ya deux choses
différentes effectivement moi hier par
exemple j'étais contre ce que disait
david niess pas parce que c'est un élu
de la république et que l'élu ne doit
pas parlé avec émotion mais avec du
recul vers david lisnard quand vous sera
calme n'ont aucun problème est
d'ailleurs sur l'autre partie de sa
phrase que j'étais d'accord mais bon peu
importe mais en l'occurrence la
famille de victimes les familles de
victimes ont tous les droits ils ont
droit de tout dire ils ont droit de
parler avec le coeur ils ont reparlé
avec les émotions ils ont reparlé avec
les larmes ils ont droit de pas avoir de
recul donc c'est pour ça que je
différencie un élu de la république est
en revanche une personne qui a vécu
intimement et dans sa chair le fait que
sa maman a été dans une situation
absolument dramatique lui il a tous les
droits voilà que ben moi je trouve qu
avant il y avait de la criminalité en
france que les as police aujourd'hui à
la barbarie c'est un truc incroyable et
face à la barbarie pour moi la seule
réponse c'est la violence alors c'est
horrible mais y'a pas d'autre réponse et
je comprends tout à fait ce qu'ils ont
dit et et voilà je ne cautionne alors
que je ne suis pas familles des victimes
guillaume tête et comme si la wii je
pense qu'on peut pas ressentir ce que
ressent ce monsieur temps qu'on l'a pas
vécu donc c'est sa maman évidemment son
émotion je lis damman mais si on sort de
rimatara sa place mais c'est pour ça on
se masse atlas mission au sort de
l'émotion je pense qu'à froid on ne peut
pas dire qu'aujourd'hui quand vous voyez
quelqu'un agresser quelqu'un
la réponse est de répondre par la
violence en tuant sept personnes je
pense que c'est pas possible parce que
ça envoie un mauvais signal celui d'une
société à l'américaine où tout le monde
a son arme tout mon à son flingue et
s'en sert quand il le veut et chacun
fait sa loi etc et hier on avait aussi
aussi qu est le neveu dali qui a vécu
aussi un drame et son son oncle est mort
d'une situation similaire lui il a gardé
son son sang froid et il dit qu'il n'en
veut pas aux victimes et dit que la
justice va faire son travail donc je
comprends tout à fait l'émotion de ce
monsieur encore une fois on peut pas se
mettre à sa place et je pense que c'est
pas une bonne une solution de répondre à
la violence par la violence vraiment moi
je connais quand il dit je les tue ça se
trouve il veut juste dire qu'il va la
bagarre il veut dire qu'il leur rentrer
dedans qui les frappe et je ne sais même
pas s'il va aller jusqu'à les tuer mais
moi je comprends je le comprends parce
que je vous dire qu'un fils tu fais ça
tu y vois ça un moment dans cet état là
je peux comprendre qu'il ait pris par
l'émotion je peux comprendre qu'il ait
qui dit ça parce que pour lui c'est
inadmissible 89 ans et il lui il a bien
dit que eux étaient venus pour tuer sa
maman le cookie mais il frappe pour tuer
ce moment moi je comprends je comprends
je suis pas dans le truc à dire non non
c'est pas grave il avait que 14 ans
c'est pas de leur faute c'est des
enfants un savez il faut qu'ils aient
jeunesse se passe maintenant 14 ans
était déjà quelqu'un 14 ans tu de la
grèce par des vieilles dames moi je
comprends chez avec lui faut que
jeunesse se passe une phrase que vous
avez souvent dit et benjamins non je
trouve que en fait la vérité c'est qu'il
a non seulement c'est pas l'émotion je
pense qu'il a le droit de le dire parce
que c'est sa maman et je pense que l'on
aurait tous dit la même chose voici ma
mère l'a attaqué je n'ai qu'une envie
c'est de me venger alors c'est très mal
de le penser mais faut être honnête
c'est tout le monde il faut bien penser
banon je suis allé quand on fait du mal
à tâtons enfants quand on fait du mal à
ta mère ton père tu as envie de te
venger tandis que qu' il ya une façon de
préparer ruiz il a dit et voit nettement
je pense exactement comme lille surtout
il a le droit de dire et de l'exprimer
après un peu choqué et lent mais je vois
pas ce qu'on pourrait dire d'autre quand
on était dans une telle situation c'est
horrible à les frapper une dame de 90
ans j'ai qu'une envie effectivement
cessé ces mecs là c'est des massacrés
alors c'est c'est interdit par la loi
mais se désole c'est très logique de
penser et de le dire surtout si c'est
horrible c'est horrible et les jeunes on
le disait hier n'ont même pas manifesté
de regrets quand ils ont avoué qu'ils
sont coupables même pas de regret donc
tout est horrible mais c'est c'est pas
ça qu'on évoque là c'est le fait de dire
j'aurais pu les tuer si vous répondez à
la violence pour la violence est
chaudronnier la mobilisation moi
j'aurais pas dit je vais les tuer je
rédige et j'espère qu'ils auront un
châtiment exemplaire et qui seront
condamnés à de la prison ferme mais
j'aurais pu filmer des phrases et
il ya un moment donné bah vous aurez ma
violence on parle de deux gamins de 14
ans qui ont pris de l'élan pour tuer oui
frappé pour tuer une femme de 90 ans ou
30 euros nous voulons définir dans quel
monde tu as vu venir vous aurez même la
violence maintenant il faut il faut
prendre des dispositions qui vont au
delà de ça il faut que la peur change de
camp il faut que ces gens sachent que si
on les chope sur le moment eh bien ils
peuvent être ils peuvent avoir la même
violence et que de la même manière c'est
ça ce qu'il faut aujourd'hui par dont
ckoi de tanus et
si ce monsieur là c'est pas un excès
l'art est mature d'année un peu loin
mathieu là tu fais là c'est vrai que tu
fais dans les émotions si la wii c'est
dans les émotions
la violence ou diront je veux dire à ces
jeunes il faut qu'ils aient des trucs
qu'ils soient amis en sport en place
pour dire à ces jeunes de 14 ans quand
vous allez faire quelque chose
maintenant exane est attrapé mais
il faudra le faire un moment donné il
faudra arrêter de dire parce que c'est
un mineur il est rappelé en prison parce
que cinq mineurs il aura rien parce que
ce et le savent le savent très bien que
comme ils disent à peine ils vont en
garde à vue ils sont déjà dehors mathieu
je te sens tu restes chez toi vraiment
d'abord je reconnais que mon enfant moi
ma grand mère était très proche était
coupé du cube est élevé par ma
grand-mère les les personnes âgées des
seniors les personnes qui sont faibles
et fragiles hommes et femmes ça me
touche ça me touche énormément
zoug est une lâcheté sans nom ma grande
tante pareil qui avait 92 ans qu'à tirer
de l'argent il ya deux mecs un revenu
qui ont tiré tiré son sac à main qui
n'ont qui l'ont fait tomber on sait
qu'une femme qui tombe à cet âge là c
est ce qu a ce quelque chose
finie elle est morte donc pas imaginer
si j'avais une voiture à ce moment le
genre est roulé c'est une haine que j'ai
quand j'ai vu ce monsieur à côté de moi
c'est une haine que j'ai de cette femme
ça me touche tellement c'est tellement
dégueulasse et j'en ai marre
effectivement qu'on entende il faut
prendre des dispositions parce que c'est
ce qui va se passer aujourd'hui à un
débat en chasse un autre dans une
semaine durant un autre massacre on en
est aujourd'hui à metz aujourd'hui où un
mec est quelqu'un avec un nunchaku et
pour passer à autre chose et puis le
débat ça va être terminé jusqu'au
prochain débat donc non il y en a marre
des il faut qu' il ne se passe rien ces
gamins ils vont prendre quoi 114 ans
aller au maximum trois ans peut-être
deux ans à 16 ans ils sortent de là et
se terminer même cette géniale vie de
lesnar a dit qu'il voulait lui il
proposait à gérald darmanin non mais oui
de supprimer l'excusé de minorité sont
la grande vague ça sur mes mais mathieu
lajoie qui est joli pour les
téléspectateurs parce que voilà il ya
beaucoup de gens qui réagissent aux
propos de mathieu mathieu là nous
expliquer pourquoi il parlait sous le
coup d'un sur l'émotion je n'avais pas
voilà que tu as vu les seuls à ma grande
tante 81 94 ans avait exactement il tire
de l'argent comme ça et est en plus de
trois 3 mecs qui viennent on est dans la
lâcheté la pire
époque des gamins agressent quelqu'un
général c'est une fille dans le métro
une fille dans le rer une vieille dame
cessé au delà de tourner dans la
barbarie on est dans la lâcheté c'est
horrible de vous dire que je pensais je
pensais que dans cette société encore
les seules personnes qui pourraient être
dans la rue à travers il peut respecter
c'est les seniors effectivement les
seniors aujourd'hui ont peur cette femme
à avoir peur est effectivement vous avez
raison lire il faut la suivre j'espère
qu'il y aura pas de droit sur hier c'est
bien d'avoir peur peur de sortir de chez
elle birds c'est horrible mais là il ya
beaucoup de gens qui disent aussi merci
mathieu je dis oui pardon bientôt si
c'est excessif c'est la même émotion que
ce monsieur à côté ça m'a tellement
touché hier non mais c'est sûr il ya
beaucoup de personnes
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est vrai que mathieu et non
il ya des gens qui comprennent que tu
dis aussi je vous êtes d'accord il va
rien se passer est que dans une semaine
y aura d'autres gosses parce que
malheureusement il ya tellement
aujourd'hui de crimes de violence que
dans une semaine y aura un autre buzz on
parlera d'un autre débat et celui là
sera chassé ne se passera rien c'est
vrai mais c'est moi moi moi je suis
fière je le dis aussi bien sûr il
s'appelle pas faire vengeance soi-même
etc mais c'est vrai que je suis dans ce
cas dit mathieu je reconnais une chose
c'est quand vous avez un petit peu lit
que david lisnard le maire de cannes
avait été un petit peu loin parce que
c'est un élu la république je vous dire
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on en a ras le
cul et les deux français on aura le cul
que les élus de la république parle
comme des élus de la république ils ont
envie qui parlent comme des citoyens
lambda ils les ont élus pour qu'ils
parlent comme nous pour qu'ils
s'expriment comme nous pour qu'ils
ressentent les mêmes choses que nous les
phrases toutes faites quand il arrive
sur un drame et qui disent c'est
inadmissible on va tout faire pour que
ça se reproduise plus on sait très bien
que ça ne sert à rien voilà ce qui se
passera jamais rien voilà c'est bon là
on l'a vu ça fait des années que ça dure
oui et ils arrivent ils vont sur les
lieux et c'est inadmissible et on va on
va on va faire le maximum pour qu'il y
ait des sanctions après bien entendu les
gens oublient on passe à un autre buzz
comme animateur et un autre drame et ça
recommence et puis après on débat on a
oublié et comme marilyn de rien c'est
vrai que un buzz en chasse un autre
passager en chasse un autre aujourd'hui
et bien ça y est on a oublié et dans une
loi dans un mois on aura oublié voilà ce
qui s'est passé bien prêt pour la maman
de 2,2 de ce monsieur et c'est vrai que
mathieu je sais que tu parle avec
émotion il dirait que
mathieu il dit pas et vous dis pas
faites-vous violences faites vous
justice vous même nom mais juste avec
son coeur est avec ses émotions avec
l'expérience qu'il a eue exaltant sa
femme il exhale assure je dis aux gens à
les tuer tous les essais s'est mal
exprimé ce que je dis effectivement et
c'est ça qui me choque c'est qu'à chaque
fois il ya un sujet que dans un journal
et on se pose la question de la violence
sur ça va durer 24 heures et pendant 48
heures terminé merci au revoir et on
passe à autre chose il ne se serait rien
passé et et voilà et donc je comprends
ce que tu dit gilles mais il ya un
moment il faut au yoyo ce monsieur à
côté hier qu'ils diminuent et que ces
mots que je sais pas mais ce prix mais
on les donnait la parole il n'aurait
jamais eu sinon effectivement
cessé c'est horrible lahoud c'est pire
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on est en train de
se poser la question est-ce que c'est
lui qui nous a choqués
c'est vrai qu'il a raison
x ou dit hier il allait bien pensants
dans les réseaux sociaux qui se sont
acharnés contre ce monsieur vincent est
alors que et un moment épique ans
s'accroît et bien pensants il pense à la
maman de ce monsieur il pense à ce qu'il
a ressenti quand il a vu sa maman se
faire frapper par derrière comme ça
prend d'un coup d'une violence extrême
non il faut pas dire s'il faut pas dire
ça c'est à cause de gens comme ça que la
société on est où elle en est
aujourd'hui ils font ils font reculer la
société il ne vaut pas les problèmes ils
sont que dans le débat stérile et c'est
insupportable et je vous dis çà çà çà c
est moi je vois quand j'ai vu le
monsieur hier voilà c'est vrai qu'on
doit pas se faire justice soi même et
c'est insupportable ce qu'il a vu et
esquisser c'est moi j'ai encore vu les
images au long du jeu voulues j'ai
encore vu les images et je me dis mais
c'est si c'est pas possible bien sûr on
va suivre cette affaire et on va savoir
ce qui s'est passé parce que c'est vrai
que même nous parle de la faire parfois
avec puis après on n'en parle pas et on
sait pas ce qui s'est passé banques sur
la honda on va ça vous dire à ces
quelques champions après voilà et
quelles sanctions il ya eu et gide je
vais te dire mon jules sait très bien ce
que tu dis tu es un citoyen vraiment
parfait mais je pense vraiment que tu es
dans une ancienne société on ne dit pas
que c'est une société dans laquelle il
faut se faire vengeance old men faut se
faire justice soi même mais on est dans
une société où tout ce que tu dis c'est
de l'ancien temps et aujourd'hui on a vu
que ce que tu lis ça ne marche pas c'est
exactement au discours de politique
c'est de la politique qui a été fait
depuis des années depuis des décennies
et des décennies et on voit que c'est de
pire en pire donc je te le dis ce n'est
pas je pense le bon discours après je
trouve que c'est toi qui elle doit avoir
raison parce que c'est vrai que c'est
toi le plus mesuré mais vraiment je te
dis qu'on voit que ça ne marche pas mon
chéri ont cessé ça va pas oui mais je
vous ai regardé hier et c'est vrai que
ça m'a pas choqué ces propos parce que
je me suis dit la même chose en fait je
me suis dit mais moi ma grand-mère qui
aujourd'hui à 90 dans et à la peur de
sortir dans la rue elle tient son sac à
main comme ça elle cache ses bijoux mais
dans quel monde on vit c'est pas normal
qu'une personne de 81 ans et peur de
sortir dans la rue par peur se faire
agresser et moins de monde c'est ça à
mes à une de mes grands mères
sait on peut tuer coiffe insulté une
réaction alors y'a bouder qui dit qu'il
est tout coeur avec toi mon mathieu
gentil ceux d'en bas qui s'embrassent à
ohrid a été touché par par tt voilà 208
s'entraider lui et tu te dis qu'il te
fais un gros bisou